hey mom stoves not working you're
cooking trying but the stove want like
okay first of all turn off all the knobs
so you don't blow yourself up and then
lift up the top of the stove in the
little things you see in between the
burners um okay just put a match on them
and they should light up in the burner
should work nice the worked thanks mom
now we just need to teach you how to
cook what's wrong what nothing just
trying to hang a cheer from the ceiling
you're what that's one of those hammock
Cheers well just make sure you anchor
into the ceiling joists how do i find
the joist or the stud finder okay then
just drill a five inch pilot hole screw
the eye bolt in hang the air suck on the
eyeball the just changing you're done um
I need to borrow your stud finder and
your drill also can you repeat
everything you just said mom I got the
job oh honey that's great congrats I
have to go back in there and talk about
celery oh honey just negotiate I can't
do that okay let's practice we're
prepared to offer you a starting salary
of $50,000 100,000 Ashley baby you have
to go lower 60,000 we can start you off
at 55 deal Ashley you're gonna do great
okay remember to call me afterwards okay
we can offer you 40 thousand I'll take
it okay so good news is it is all
fixable well yeah you got a broken AC
broken AC need to replace the cabin air
filter gotta replace my my cabin and
your tires are bald tell your our ball
yeah you want me fix it take care of
everything it's good sign right here you
know if you could just give me a minute
yeah sure sure sure what's wrong I'm at
the mechanic he says there's a bunch of
stuff wrong with my car my tires are
bald and my AC is not working altars
busted or something okay look you
definitely got to get the tires that's
the most important thing we'll figure
something else out for the other stuff
right okay cool thanks that yeah so I'm
just gonna throw some new shoes on this
baby tires i mean you know new tires
thank you
alright enjoy those new shoes
[Music]